you talk about and this is a fascinating
part and when you're a teenager this
would be traumatic for a lot of people
you start going bald as a teenager and
you're completely bald you said almost
by the age 19 20 21 somewhere around
there and you just decided I'm going to
make this work for me because you
realized I'm the per wigs I I'm the
perfect I can wear any wig in the world
now because I am an actor and I play
different parts to to make that an asset
when and it has been an I mean it's it's
uh it's you to figure that out I think
it's such a big thing in life to when
you're when you're dealt a certain card
to say I'm going to make this work for
me and it has worked beautifully yes it
has it nevertheless wasn't easy as a in
my late teens to find that I was losing
my hair and I lost it so quickly and I
come from a family of bald men mhm my
brothers my father my grand grandfather
actually no Freedom had hair a lot of
hair his name was Freedom barlu now
that's Victorian if ever there that's
fantastic pardon that's fantastic it is
yes um
but one of the things I very quickly
realized because I'm I'm quite
interested in
economics um Brent Spiner calls it um my
poverty mentality m mhm he said you were
poor when you were little and you've
never ever got past that point part of
you is still stuck in the poverty region
and uh I think that he was right and
I I so losing my hair felt like a
failure MH and
also you know dating
yeah who wants to go out with a an
18yearold who's just got a
few and I I used to do all this combing
it over you know and then uh one day uh
a director I was working with who was
very very conscious of costs said to me
oh no no no you're two actors for the
price of one oh my
God these are okay yeah that's right
with any with wigs we can get through
three rolls out of you yeah that's
fantastic exactly and I've had some
Sensational wigs in my in my lifetime
really because you know they say the wig
maker says you were born to wear wigs
you know maybe it's not the biggest
compliment you were born to wear a
mask what right right
right so you so you you're moving up in
the world you're making your way you
moved to London and there's a part in
the book because you had led this very
sheltered life in mirfield and you had
been taught all these stereotypes and
one of the stereotypes you'd been taught
was don't trust the
Irish and um you move into a flat and
there's some Irishmen no it was it was a
lodging house lodging house okay first
of all I still believe don't trust the
Irish solid advice and I'm 100% so I am
you come to this wonderful Revelation
that no that's wrong these are wonderful
people I think whoever told you don't
trust the Irish was spot on but we'll
let that go for now um I'm glad you had
a good experience with them I had a
wonderful experience there were all
young men they'd mostly come from the
west coast of Ireland um and they
because they needed work at that time in
the late' 40s there was a there was a
job shortage significant one and people
were people were dying because they
couldn't feed themselves right and all
these young guys had come over to London
to get work and they were all working on
building sites they were laborers uh
nobody was a
skilled Constructor they were they were
laborers
and they welcomed me into the I shared a
bedroom with one it was two in single
beds yeah and uh over the first night
when we had dinner uh one of them he he
introduced me to everybody around they
were all Irish and he said listen when
when dinner's over we go out cuz there's
a pub around the corner that's very
Irish friendly and he said your name is
Patrick I mean it couldn't be
better we can introduce you to anyone
put on this leprechaun wig yeah that's
right